it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games and new releases
and this week the base building
community fearing zombie smashing open
world of state of decay is out
originally released in 2013 for xbox 360
the Xbox one version is fully remastered
in 1080p with improved lighting textures
animations and combat mechanics plus
extra content including new missions and
weapons pick your friends carefully this
zombie survival game comes to Xbox one
on the 28th double find fans get the
completed story this week with broken
age act to releasing new fans of the
game can grab the complete adventure on
pc ps4 and Vita follow Vela and Shea as
they're very different worlds start to
intertwine this beautifully hand-painted
adventure is filled with interesting
characters witty jokes and delicious
cake and ice cream around every turn the
end of a wonderful community driven
point-and-click adventure starts on the
28th this week a beloved PvP game that
has almost as much action as it does
silly characters is testing its way out
of early access magica wizard wars puts
your spell-casting skills to the test
forming teams for and combining each of
your unique magic elements to create
spell combinations that can kill your
enemies or each other because friendly
fire is on and it's fun to kill your
friends in that traditional magic away
there's a bunch of varying robes saph
skins weapons and humor to create the
wizard of your dreams wage war on
Wizards on the 28th also this week
dictators cross the Seas to explore and
conquer new worlds on the ps4 tropico 5
is SimCity on steroids as you run a
country instead of a city trading and
communicating with other countries until
you have an army to go to war and take
them for everything they've got ignore
environmentalists and mindless [ __ ] out
of your country offer military jobs and
free housing and free healthcare and
become the most beloved modern military
dictator the world is ever seen make
them love you on the 28th finally I have
to let you know that kerbal space
program is lifting off from early access
and into full release build a spaceship
watch a crash and then build it again to
learn mysteries of Aeronautics and
investigate worlds beyond what our eyes
can see there is an official trailer but
this video made by sean s AO truly
embodies with this game is a pure
feeling of childlike wonder if you
haven't yet give it a try it launches on
the 27th for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week
you